hey I'm Christian it's a great notice oh
well this is very sweet thank you so
much Alicia for remembering my birthday
like somebody else what everybody was
like hey guys it was Christian's
birthday this weekend what are we gonna
do on the show for him well I text
everybody let him know that you lost
again but we're not gonna get to that
right now we're gonna let well tell them
later what the punishment is and all
that great stuff but we have Alicia
Malone here is it safe to say that you
see every single movie that comes out
yeah I was thinking about it and I
probably averaged between five and ten
movies awake and then you go to all the
festivals all the festivals I have no
life and I'm gonna die aligned but I
know a lot of bad films or you have the
best life ever
I mean you literally see everything and
I know you're as excited for me for the
force awakens so we're just entire
episodes just gonna be about before so
please like star wars that much guys
just put it out there yeah you actually
do want to see the new movie I would
love to be sitting next to you guys
because I know you cried in the trailer
I'm not ashamed to say I want to watch
that I want to watch that happen but I'm
also looking forward to the revenant
yeah Ellen I'm very inner a - I mean
you're Birdman was one of my favorite
films from last year and that last
trailer that just came out with Leonardo
there's a bear
I love all movies and it is and I am
obviously Star Wars is my thing litter I
love some movies I loved we are your
friends are you got me what Marvel has
done what Star Wars is no Warner
Brothers starting to do them with DC is
taking these directors and actors from
these independent films have you seen a
lot in the last couple years yeah and I
love you know feeling like the
pretentious but on my high horse be like
oh yeah well I saw that directors film
at a film festival and I knew gives up
for big things now look to be what what
are you doing to me what I had to put
this poster but just like burned into my
brain er it's burnt in your brain
because Tiffany a weak-minded fool the
machinima et Cie guys have the winners
we love winning and they're using it
against you do whatever lands on like
baked into the brains or something yeah
do they have to take down one of the
frames behind them and replace it with a
poster of us yeah Alicia so machinima et
Cie guys they stole our wheel they say
oh we know what movies are you guys and
now they have turned my poor hobo spirit
to what let's move on to the weekly
wager but every single week Christian I
guess what the movies are gonna open up
at with the box-office wagers well I
love this part of the show and I think
keeping an eye on it and so I remember
last week the Martian yes Tiffany said
50 million Christian said fifty eight
million the actual box office was
the 4.3 million which means now to
celebrate my fifth victory we're all
gonna eat this cake the crap out of you
you sexy beast you're so weird but first
let's find out what Tiffany's punishment
is this week's loser should comes from
YouTube viewer what he's doing right but
it comes from a YouTube viewer who says
I can I know what are you doing no no
what are you go to my cake 21 pucks who
says loser should sit on a birthday cake
all right but cake we all know Martians
gonna be number one again so let's talk
about pan Joe Wright directs this movie
it has huge act when is Blackbeard and
will make twenty six point five million
I am going to go with 23 million I was
gonna say like 40 million so I think I
would be why uh don't forget to submit
your hashtag loser shuns in the YouTube
comments below on Twitter and on
Facebook what is happening today's topic
which means Halloween is rapidly
approaching yes Alfred Hitchcock is my
jam if you could give us your top 5
Alfred Hitchcock movies in season what
would they be well you have to start
with the ultimate Hitchcock classic that
is psycho with a great score it's all
shot in black and white and this changed
the horror game because it had this big
twist then of course there's the birds
and it's such an interesting
because it's got a lot of metaphors
about nature versus man but poor Tippi
Hedren got absolutely terrorized tree
they're not actually gonna fly at you
and then they did but it makes for a
really terrifying film yeah
my favorite Hitchcock is rear window
starring Jimmy Stewart he plays a
photographer who is voyeuristic about
his neighbors and I love the way it
turns of voyeurism on the audience
because we realize you're watching him
watching everyone else and that we all
love watching people Tiffani vertigo is
another really good classic it's about a
retired detective who starts to
investigate his friend's wife it's
really beautifully shot finally dial M
for murder this is an absolute classic
about a murder plot gone horribly wrong
so I know some of you out there might
not have seen Hitchcock movies but I'm
gonna challenge you to go and watch one
I would suggest rear window because it
is such an interesting self-contained
movie and it is fascinating I know these
movies are old they've influenced
everything particularly in the horror
genre you know what I wanted to mention
before when we're talking about the
birds rot Taylor's in that movie rot
tell happens to be from Australia like
Alicia is and I've been dying to ask you
this a whole show actors and actresses
from Australia because it's Tiffany
that's my Australian accent we've
offended every Australians ever laughs
so here are the rules of name that
famous Australian I am going to describe
these actors and there are specific
words that I'm not allowed to say and
Alisha you've got 30 seconds to try and
get
are you ready this is my favorite game
okay really funny blonde she beatbox to
get an audition for this movie rabbu-l
says okay next one sheep Wolverine yeah
Jack yeah and okay she is married to
country singer youth undocumented his
first movie he was he was an accident
college - yeah okay she is now Alicia
normally we have a pretty good winners
we love winning
but those rotten rats over at machinima
HCC took our wheel so we have this thing
this is where you're gonna have to spend
this week because you did such a good
job alright give it a spin please use
your might wheel sucks got a good clip
for us right yeah you guys know I like
interviewing celebrities yes things
don't often go quite as planned so I
brought with you a collection of awkward
moments with Alicia do you find that
easier or quicker to access your emotion
these days as
as I get on I'm fine
you're awkward speaking of awkward
moment I'm gonna go yeah okay Cass all
right well here's an awkward moment
Tiffany killed Rainbow Brite I don't
know what to say I apologize Fandango
her show profiles and her own YouTube
channel movies are my jam
Alicia below yay thanks for having me
and I forget you can subscribe by
pushing this button and you can also
check out all the hilarity from previous
episodes by pressing this button
absolutely and make sure that you check
out the offend angle movie clips app on
your smartphone then come right back
here to watch us on movie three so